es 17 de diciembre de 2010 la calle
tunecina se levanta la revolución no es
sólo política también es cultural
[Música]
en los muros del país aparecen pinturas
y graffitis con connotaciones políticas
el arte se convierte en un medio de
expresión y una herramienta de
información varios artistas jóvenes
crearon colectivos como al café los
habitantes de las cuevas como éramos
tres amigos estudiantes de la escuela de
bellas artes del lunes y fue allí donde
fundamos el movimiento al alca
proclama empezamos a pintar grafitis en
los muros de la plaza de calva graffiti
satíricos contra el régimen
nadie más
[Música]
luego egipto responde también al llamado
de libertad y como en túnez el arte
ocupa un lugar primordial
[Música]
en la plaza tahir de el cairo los
grandes artistas tradicionales se
transforman en moralistas el pueblo
exige libertad y los artistas responden
a esta oleada de esperanza los muros de
la capital egipcia permiten a los
ciudadanos estar informados también son
un medio para la crítica satírica de las
autoridades a diferencia de los medios
tradicionales que son allegados al
gobierno el mundo de la música está
viviendo su propia revolución las
celebridades de instituciones artísticas
tradicionales están dejando paso a
jóvenes músicos como el grupo kairo
[Música]
a 2000 km lleven también se levanta las
mujeres cantan en la calle y ante miles
de personas un actor se burla
abiertamente del poder
[Música]
martín es mi objetivo
los muros de la plaza del cambio
epicentro de la protesta también se
convierten en lienzos donde los
ciudadanos pueden expresar sus
esperanzas incluso se organizan talleres
en los que miles de personas se
familiarizan con el dibujo animado
voy a reír de la uva con su línea al
extra
en libia este rapero que se hace llamar
el filósofo se dirige directamente a
moamar al gadafi que lleva más de 40
años en el poder pidiéndole que renuncie
los artistas locales inventaron un nuevo
estilo de frescos murales combinando la
caligrafía árabe con los colores del
arte pop las obras se conservan y dos
años después muchos artistas de países
como túnez y egipto viajan a libia y
aprovechan para añadir sus obras y
mensajes transformando las calles del
país en una exposición al aire libre
el viento de la protesta sopla hasta
siria pero la revolución que comenzó con
grafitis en las paredes se convirtió
rápidamente en un baño de sangre lo que
llevó al cantante esa misión caer a
escribir ya hide en español que pesar y
hacer
voy a hacer
la canción se convierte en un himno de
la revolución que consigue sobrevivir
durante unos meses a pesar de la
represión las obras de arte se
multiplican pero los artistas buscan
permanecer en el anonimato
pocas personas declaran públicamente su
apoyo al movimiento de protesta y entre
ellos la actriz jaua suleimán y el
futbolista ante el casete alzaron que
movilizan a la multitud con cosas
[Aplausos]
[Música]
han pasado 10 años desde que el pueblo
se levantó contra sus líderes
revoluciones amenudo reprimidas que
perdieron su esencia y se alejaron de
las esperanzas de 2011 hoy en día este
arte popular es testigo del espíritu de
la primavera árabe un recuerdo de un
periodo en el que todas las esperanzas
estaban permitidas